it's a new year new possibilities new
options new hope so it's vitally
important that we spin on our heels 180
degrees and take a careful look at what
just happened
was any of it good
i don't know let's see
[Music]
2021 sure was
a thing
it i don't
i don't know
how comfortable i am saying it was
better than 2020.
a lot of what was new in 2020 have
become routine but i don't think that's
a good thing
but anyways normally this is where i
would do well you go way back i was
doing my top 10 movies of the previous
year
last year i changed that to my favorite
pieces of entertainment for the previous
year and i'm gonna do that but i'm also
gonna do like sort of a quick look back
at what the year had for me because
this is my job now and i've completed
now more than the first year of this
being my full-time job and yeah i kind
of want to look back on that a little
bit as far as my own output goes i'm
fairly happy with what i did this year i
will say i'm not thrilled about the fact
that most of my most viewed videos from
this year were in some way addressing
drama that i wish i didn't have to
address at all so things like
no clark john barrowman amber heard joss
whedon gina carano yeah yeah i talked
about that way early in this year that's
how long it's been while i don't intend
to stop doing that kind of stuff i do
get annoyed that that's usually some of
my more viewed stuff cause
a lot of my talking about that is
partly just processing my own stuff and
hoping that it will help other people
process their sense of these things
it's not what i want the channel to be
about but it seems to be what the
algorithm wants me to be i'm not going
to lean into it any harder than i
already have but that was sort of my
annoyance for the year
thankfully my most viewed videos were
not among those the single most viewed
video i did was the one talking about
the way in which we discuss
various creators on this platform coming
out that video did quite well i think i
managed to just catch the uh the wave of
interest on the topic um it's funny
sometimes doing topical stuff it just
tanks other times i manage to snag the
the interest and the algorithm shines
its favor upon me briefly
that said the second most viewed video i
did this year was a real pleasant
surprise and that was the video i did on
the ethics and implications of body swap
stories now
that was one that i put a fair amount of
work into but usually the ones that i
put that amount of work into i kind of
expect to not do super well like the one
i did about not really complex villains
that are trying to appear complex or the
one that i did as an overview of falcon
in the winter soldier i put comparable
amounts of work into them they didn't
really go anywhere i don't know if i
just managed to strike a niche that like
nobody else was talking about but that
one did surprisingly and had legs people
kept coming back to that one for a while
after it went up that was a pleasant
surprise uh by far the video that i'm
most proud of is the one where i spoke
with james stephanie sterling jxe mae
leets and jessie earl of jesse gender
and i'm just really really well i'm
really really happy that they were all
willing to speak to me about the
experience of coming out on a platform
like this
and i'm really happy with how i was able
to cut that together the entire project
was a completely different kind of work
for me i'd never really done that kind
of editing before but it came
surprisingly naturally just sort of
feeling the flow and the moments to go
from one of them to the other and at
what points to shift topics and i'm
really really proud of that it did
decently actually i'd say slightly
better than i thought it might do but um
that's the one that i would have most
liked to have been the highest viewed
one it isn't but i would have liked it
my novel was published this year dreams
of fire yes there's links to buy down in
the description uh and i'm
really really happy with that and i've
been very pleased with the reception uh
if by any chance you have gotten a copy
and you've read it and haven't written a
review on say goodreads i i would
appreciate it could use some more but i
have been very happy from the feedback
that i've gotten from those who have
written reviews or have reached out to
tell me about it and that was that was a
major accomplishment i've been working
on that thing for
about 19 years
yeah roundabout
yeah
now before i get into this most of these
i have reviewed just not on this channel
i actually do my reviews on the break
room of geeks the subsidiary channel
where most of my review material goes so
consider subscribing there if you
haven't already as far as entertainment
that i took in this year it's been a
little bit of an odd year because there
was lots of stuff that i liked but it's
been surprising to me how much of it
hasn't stuck with me as much as i would
have expected for example
i quite liked ryan the last dragon i
quite liked ghostbusters afterlife i
liked the suicide squad i liked luca i
liked chang chi that snyder kind of
justice league came out you know what it
wasn't bad
but very few of these things have left a
lasting impact and i felt very little
drive to go and try and seek them out
and watch them again
nor have they occupied much of my brain
space since having seen them even
spiderman no way home which is fairly
recent and i did like very much it isn't
leaving as much of a lasting impression
as i thought it might given how much i
liked it initially honestly as far as
movies or what i'm going to choose to
classify as movies go there were really
only three that stuck with me enough
that i feel like they're worth really
highlighting
and one of them is fairly recent but i'm
still
i still feel comfortable doing that
most recently
there's encanto now if you haven't seen
my review it should be up in the break
room of geeks by now
this is one that it's funny
when i watched it i was like i like that
and then in the process of actually
shooting my review for it and i just
sort of talked about what it was doing
and how it went about it i was realizing
i actually like this more
the more that i talk about it and even
since shooting after that review i like
it more the more i think about it which
has happened to me with some disney
movies that happened to me was zootopia
that happened to me with moana that
happened to me with wreck-it ralph
doesn't happen to me with all of them
some of them i'm just like yeah that was
fine and it kind of stays there but the
more i think about what encanto was
doing and the way that it approaches
family dynamics and tells a story
ultimately about family connections and
trying to find the balance between being
who you are while also
being respectful and honoring those
around you
and sort of
creating a cautionary tale about the
idea of letting the family and what's
good for the family become this
nebulous thing that is almost separate
from the people
that are supposed to make up that family
it's interesting because on paper this
had the potential to dip into something
that i hate because i hate stories that
basically amount to you have to forgive
your family because they're family and i
hate that i hate that because that is a
narrative used by incredibly toxic
people to worm their way back into the
lives of family members that they have
and likely will continue to hurt so i
have a big problem with that but that
isn't what this is doing it does have
aspects of don't shun your family but
it's not just on the basis of because
they're family it's all centered around
this idea of remember that your family
isn't an institution it is people
and keep an eye on those people because
maybe they need help
and maybe the things that they're doing
that aren't working for you is them
trying to help
it's really well done and the more i
think about it the more i really like it
another film that i really enjoyed this
year and
other reviewers might call this a guilty
pleasure i'm not gonna do that because i
feel absolutely no guilt about loving
this but i will call this my um shallow
no real depth to it
pick of the year and that is gunpowder
milkshake
i had
so much fun
with this movie the action scenes are
awesome and inventive like i don't think
uh there's any other movie where you're
going to see a panda-shaped suitcase
used as the weapon or where you're going
to see these people in
such rough shape who can barely even use
their limbs still trying to kill each
other it's like you if you've seen um
atomic blonde how worn out
charlize and the guy she was fighting
were at the end of that really long
standing fight scene imagine a fight
scene starting and they're already that
worn out
that's in gunpowder milkshake the
characters are fun the actors bring so
much sense of personality and history to
them just by being there are they
extremely well sketched out and with
deep senses of lore no but there's so
much personality injected just by the
people that they cast that you feel like
there's history regardless i had just
pure unadulterated joyful fun
with this movie it's to a degree that
i wanted the suicide squad to be but as
i said the suicide squad while i did
like it hasn't stuck with me i do keep
thinking about gunpowder milkshake
though
i really love it now the thing that i'm
going to choose to label a movie that
probably left the largest impact on me
is
bo burnham's inside which i know
hit a lot of people
very hard it hit me on multiple levels
one because i feel like it connected to
what is i'm not gonna say universal but
a very shared experience of what it felt
like trying to be productive uh in the
pandemic especially if you're creative
as well as being a deconstruction of the
comedy special in particular and as
someone who
loves stand-up comedy but has become
increasingly jaded by it just because
it's become very formulaic
seeing somebody break apart the rules of
a comedy special as much as this does
was exciting even aside from the fact of
how it managed to connect with me on a
more uh emotional and just gut-feeling
level
it's a heavy viewing it's not for
everybody and i have even seen some very
well-made criticisms about it and the
perspective that it has and those are
absolutely totally valid but i'd be
kidding myself if i didn't just admit
this landed really hard for me
and i am still listening to some of the
songs from it even now
going into 2022 it
hits
hard in a way that at times sneaks up on
you
and there are moments that are gentle
and then it yanks the rug out from under
you and it just connects with what
so much of the past two years now
have just felt like
whether the
pure logistics line up with your
experience or not that'll vary but
boy did that capture the mood
now when it comes to tv and streaming
i'm you know what i'll just say it i
think it was a little bit let down by a
lot of the stuff that i was excited
about i was really excited about the mcu
shows and while i liked all of them two
varying degrees
some less than others i didn't care for
a lot of what if
one division fell apart for me i really
appreciate what falcon and the winter
soldier was going for but it did miss
the mark on a few key areas loki landed
really well for me and hawkeye while
probably the least substantial
of them was just fun i think i hoped for
something
that was gonna hit at least one of these
to hit me harder loki came the closest
but it still didn't quite hit
as hard as i'd
hoped as hard as i thought it would
which i mean going into next year
i suppose that recalibrates my
expectations of these shows and maybe
that'll put me in a position to better
on to better appreciate them in the new
year because i feel like i have a much
better understanding of what they're
actually going to be versus what i had
maybe hoped they would be
none of them were a million miles away
from what i wanted but none of them
quite landed there so a shift in
expectations maybe i'll be happier next
year as far as other things go uh second
season of owl house
love it
i know that hasn't finished it has to
come back from holiday hiatus but the 10
episodes we've gotten this year
really good
it's a really great sweet
wonderful show terrifically inclusive
great characters it's just good also
this isn't a show that i've talked about
but i've also caught up on amphibia i i
have gotten through uh the episodes of
season three that are currently on
disney plus that one i don't feel as
strong a connection to it as the owl
house but
it is a lot of fun and it scratches a
not dissimilar itch but a bit like with
movies for all the streaming shows that
i saw and liked or saw and dropped off
of like star wars bad batch which i did
three episodes on and realized i just
didn't
really care
all that much uh there were three
things that i saw that came out this
year
that did land
really well for me
so the first of those
i suppose is the obvious one that i
should really get out of the way because
it blew up the conversation everywhere
and that squid game
squid game
i'd heard so many good things about it
and it was one of those things where i'm
like this isn't going to match the hype
this isn't gonna measure up to
all the excitement about it and how
memified the visuals have been like this
is gonna be
it'll be fine i'm sure but it's not
gonna be all that no
it really was
and again it's one of those things that
the more i think about it the more i
like it the more i think about how
tightly woven
the themes and the criticisms of
capitalism and what it does to people
and the divide of the rich and the poor
and how that is so tightly woven into
everything about this like
theming is something that can get away
from a project uh and especially if it
feels like theme is driving the story
more than actual narrative or characters
are it can start to feel like a lecture
but if you can find that right balance
where the theme is woven across
everything you do but the story still
works solidly as just a story about
people in circumstances even without the
thematic meanings that is when you have
hit golden this is
really hard-hitting beautifully executed
gold next up i want to single out it's a
sin the miniseries by russell t davis
this as i said in the review i actually
made it the title of the review when i
did that
this is what you get
when you let a queer creator
tell queer stories
because one of the things that's really
frustrating
as an lgbtq ia plus person
is
how many of the films tv shows etc just
the pop culture narratives about us
are created by straight
and cisgender people and it's not it
this is not me gatekeeping saying you're
not allowed to tell other people's
stories if you are going to tell other
people so you should proceed with
caution and know what you're doing
but there's simply
an appreciation and a perspective that
is almost always lacking somewhere
when there isn't a queer person involved
in key production elements
be it in the writing be it in the
director's chair or be it in the cast
and it's really hard to nail down
it's almost intangible
but
sometimes usually you can just tell
this is an outsider's perspective on
queerness
on transness on
gayness
whatever it is
you feel that slight distance
you don't feel
included you don't feel like it's
really pulling you in
you feel like
it's like a zoo it's like there's a
glass sheet there's something separating
and like you're close you can see it
clearly but you're not
there with it
it's a sin
brings you in
and you need to understand i was not
going to be automatically inclined to
relate to this
i
was alive during the time period this is
set but i don't really remember it i was
quite young
i lived in a completely different
country for all the queer experiences
i've had in my life i've never
identified as nor lived particularly
close or
existed particularly within the gay male
culture
i don't have an automatic hook in on
this
but i still felt
that
bringing in
that extending a hand and saying hey
don't be at a distance come come on
let's really get into this let's really
get into the people
let's really get into the impact
on community
that the aids epidemic
had
let's
understand these people as
people
let's understand these losses as
not just
spectacle not just
tragedy porn but as a loss of a human
being
who you will understand and appreciate
and love and be heartbroken
when they go
it's wonderfully done
i've seen some decent movies about this
topic a couple years ago i was
commissioned to watch uh a normal heart
which was also very good but this is
better this has more time this has room
to breathe it feels less like an
overview and more like an intimate
examination
and it's really
really special but then there's the show
that came out of nowhere i hadn't heard
about before it came out i had
absolutely no connection to the stuff in
which it's based off of
but i heard a lot of good things and
then i watched
arcane
as somebody who can now actually
legitimately call themselves a fantasy
writer buy my book dreams of fire link
in the description
sorry i can't help it it's automatic at
this point
i can just appreciate the depth
of the world
in a setting that never stops to lecture
me about how the world works
this focuses on characters and the depth
and understanding of everything going on
and how the conflicts and past and world
shaping events that are happening either
here or have happened previously are
forming everything is done
beautifully and naturally
i am not going to knock something like
the text crawl in star wars or the
voice over opening on lord of the rings
sometimes you need that
but if you can create a world that feels
as deep and as expansive
as star wars as middle earth without
having to ever do that
you have my full and undivided attention
and every character was perfectly
fleshed out none of these were
archetypes just filling a narrative
purpose everybody was a character no
matter how long or briefly they were in
this everybody felt like a person
which also means this is while
ultimately dealing with bigger stuff
than i dealt with in my book this is in
many ways
managing to do what i set out to do in
my own work and what i say i always like
small stories in a big world now this
does have some of the bigger stories too
but it doesn't let the big story let you
ignore the fact that there are smaller
stories going on and they
matter too
it has a beautiful sense
of scale and an understanding of you do
not have to be at the top of the pyramid
to matter you can be at the bottom and
your story still has meaning and
relevance and can hit you in the gut
with an emotional impact
you do not have to be a mover and shaker
you do not have to be someone who is
going to be written into the history
books you still matter these characters
still matter
i am really glad this is getting a
second season and finally as a broad
category to talk about you know what i
started doing this year
streaming gaming on twitch
uh which has actually made video gaming
a normal part of my routine in my life
again
that hasn't happened for a long time
granted i had to kind of integrate it
into my work day
to be able to keep a regular schedule of
it but you know if it works it works now
i've played a bunch of games this year
played two different doctor who games
lonely assassins which
may be fairly generic for the genre but
since i hadn't played those sort of
explorer phone unlock more of the phone
realize the mystery going on types games
i thought it was quite well done
uh unfortunately i also tried to play
doctor who edge of reality which was a
nightmare and terrible
i cannot turn for [ __ ] useless i cannot
see [ __ ] like [ __ ] coffee mugs holy
sh
[ __ ] designed this oh
i tried a cute little visual novel
called paranormal which i liked until it
started getting to the endings and i
played through twice just to see if i
had managed to get the worst ending but
then i got a i suppose better ending and
it was only slightly better
that that game had some issues plus
there was stuff that i played that was
not on stream i played a bunch of dead
cells this year on my switch i've
started playing a blood stained ritual
of the night need to get back to that
one but as with the other categories
there are three
games that i want to highlight although
to be fair two of them came out last
year i don't care i played them this
year i want to talk about them anyways
there is the game that has now become
the game that i have sunk the most time
into played more hours up than any other
game i've ever played in my life
and that's hades
hades
has
everything
that i wanted that dead cells didn't
give me in terms of being a roguelite
in terms of every nitpick i had about
dead cells hades addressed and did
exactly what i wanted so the gameplay
was phenomenal but the story is also
really good and the way it manages to
weave a story into the idea that you are
dying and coming back and like it's not
like oh that doesn't count try again
like no the fact that you died is
canonical and impacts the story the
story is how you keep dying while trying
to escape the greek underworld the
characters are fantastic the the art of
all these characters is great the voice
acting is wonderful the whole thing is
kind of low-key horny which like that's
my vibe i'm i'm 100 here for that love
it and it hits just the right balance so
that you have that oh just one more run
just one more just one more just one
more i can do better i i bet you i could
beat it with this weapon that i'm
normally not not that good with if i go
again if i make this modification and i
go for these boons instead of the ones i
had i i bet you i can do it this time it
really is a hard game to stop playing
and i don't regret any of the time i've
sunk into it
which has been a lot
the other game that didn't release this
year released last year but i absolutely
need to talk about
is spirit fair
another game that i played on my switch
spirit fairer is probably the single
most emotional experience i've had
playing a video game
it's
characters in the way that it meditates
on
death
is
gorgeous
and i mean that on every level visually
it's gorgeous the music is gorgeous
but
just these little things that i didn't
realize until it was over
and i started to realize all these
things that were hitting me
like the fact that after characters are
gone
whatever house
or accommodations you built for them is
still is still on your boat
you don't just get to forget them you
have reminder there that you see
every single time you play
the fact that the way things work and
helping these characters be ready to
move on
is not about
getting them happy
with it
it's not even necessarily about closure
in fact it's a lot of times about them
coming to terms with the fact that they
won't
have closure
it feels like one of the most personal
in-depth
honest and vulnerable
pieces of art that is about death
that i've ever encountered and it does
it without being dour or gloomy it's
bright and cheerful and somehow that
just makes it hit
all the harder
as far as the one game actually released
this year that i want to highlight as
being one of the best things i played is
a game that at time of recording i
haven't finished yet but probably will
have finished by the time this video
actually goes up that's death's door you
play a little crow
and you wander around trying to recover
souls
because you basically worth work for i
don't know death incorporated it's
another game ultimately about death but
play is very different from spirit
affairs certainly from a mechanical
standpoint
this is a little bit
souls-like ish in terms of needing to
master the attack patterns of characters
need to be good at dodging them when you
die it's gonna send you back a ways and
but you are always accumulating things
that you can cash in to increase your
power and it's got this wonderful
miyazaki-esque uh visual design and feel
to the characters a lot of the
characters are very very funny yet it
never
loses
that morbid sense
that ultimately what you're doing
is going around and
killing
things it doesn't let you forget that
your mission
is not a grand adventure
your job is to kill things and some
things which very very much do not want
to die and have been going through so
much effort to not do that and you're
here to end them
and as whimsical as it can be it doesn't
lose sight of that and oftentimes with
tiny little touches like the fact that
while there are some more ethereal
enemies that vanish when you kill them
there are others
whose bodies persist
and stay
on the ground with the blood splattered
around them for as long as you're in
that area
and
there were some moments where i was
venturing back through
and saw the carnage walked back through
it and realized
oh god
this is a massacre
and i did that
it's not easy to evoke that and have it
not break
the sense of whimsy and fun that the
rest of the game has but it doesn't
break it
it fits together
beautifully well there we go
i suppose that ended up being a top nine
uh
although i suppose technically a top
seven for stuff actually released this
year
it's been a strange year
and um
something tells me 2022 is going to be
strange as well probably in similar ways
maybe in new ones
but
what were your favorite pieces of
entertainment that you got to experience
this year
video games tv movies music
whatever it is
drop something down in the comments
and let's talk about it
the usual stuff you know what it is
likes and shares and subscribes and
patreon support links are in the
description for things like my book
other social media link to my twitch
channel etc etc
check that stuff out or
don't if you don't want to
if you stuck with me this far i'm
certainly not going to start telling you
what to do because
my friends
you are the council
i'm only running the meetings
and what i really want you to remember
as we get into a new year
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
and until next time
this council
is adjourned
happy new year
[Music]
none of this would have been possible
without my supporters over on patreon in
particular i want to thank robin powell
raven mcbain tracy scrabbit vincent paul
bartolucci robin moore and shayla
gourley if you'd like to hear me
possibly mispronounce your name maybe
consider looking at the reward tears
over on the patreon
but either way don't worry about it too
much
take care of yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]